-[ Grunts ]
[ Weapon whirs ]
-Ahh!
-Okay, I have a suit.
-Yeah, I noticed.
You okay?
-Yes!
-Look, momentum, right?
Jump, tap, right?
One move. Jump-tap.
-I know how to do it, Dad!
-Oh, do you?
-Yes!
-Really? 'Cause it didn't
look like it from my end.
-I messed up on the timing.
-Jump -- Ahh.
Ahh!
-Oh!
-[ Grunts ]
-Like that. You see what I did?
You see what I did?
-No.
You're like, this small.
-I jumped and tapped!
-Welcome back to "Late Night"!
We're here with Paul Rudd!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was a clip from "Ant-Man
and the Wasp: Quantumania,"
a very anticipated film.
-I don't know if this is
true or not.
Somehow, I heard word that
Schumaker was somehow able
to get tickets
on Thursday night.
-Yeah!
-Who does he know?
He's been walking around --
I guess he knows this
Jeff Fandango guy.
[ Laughter ]
-He must be high up.
-Hollywood bigwig.
High up the Marvel chain.
-That's impressive.
-This is really fun.
Third movie.
-Third one.
-Third one of the Ant-Man.
And this one's a really fun
dynamic of teenage daughter,
which you have now.
-Mm-hmm. Yep.
-How have you found being a
parent of a teenage daughter?
Are you enjoying that journey?
I know it's the front end
of being a teenager.
-It's great.
-Yeah?
-My daughter, she's just now
starting to approach that,
and I'm a little nervous.
People always say,
"Oh, teenage daughters.
There's a few years there where
it can be a little challenging."
And it hasn't been yet, but --
-She hasn't turned on you yet?
-Interview me in "Ant-Man 4."
-Yeah, okay. Got you.
-Not that there is one,
by the way.
Just, yeah.
It just seemed like that was
the right joke to say for the --
-But now everybody
at Marvel right now is
pulling their hair out.
-Yeah, that's right.
-"We told him not to
even talk about it!"
-But on "Ant-Man 7,"
I'm gonna say,
"She's the best.
She's so accepting.
And she became a real friend.
And open, and..."
-And "Ant-Man 10,"
where you're like,
"And now she has a daughter!"
-I know, it's so crazy.
It's so nuts.
You know, being a grandfather
is really something special.
A little harder to
get into the suit,
but we're managing!
-There you go.
Now I know, and we've
talked about this before.
First of all, it's always
so great to have you here.
Oftentimes, I sort of am
lucky enough to have you,
but it's the end of your
press tour, and I get it.
You're sort of exhausted about
talking about this movie.
There's probably no more
anecdotes from the set
to share.
-It's a tricky thing, you know?
You want to, "Oh,
what's been going on?
Are there any funny stories
or anything?"
And you get a little
kind of tired.
And there's only so --
-Right, it wasn't like every day
there were hijinks.
-The well gets dry.
-Yeah.
So as a favor to you,
I would like you to
tell us a story
about something
that didn't happen.
-Okay.
-Just to give you a break,
right?
-An anecdote, something that
just didn't happen to me?
-Do you want me to just make up
the top of it for you?
-Yeah, sure.
-Okay, great.
-Oh, this is my favorite
kind of water, by the way.
-Yeah?
[ Laughter ]
Well, we had a regular size,
but then we heard you wanted to
tie it into Ant-Man.
[ Laughter ]
-That's right. Yeah.
[ Applause ]
You're the best, man.
-No
-You are the best.
I will do tie-ins!
-Hold on, I'm gonna chug it.
[ Cheering ]
-Wow.
[ Applause ]
[ Crunches ]
-Oh.
[ Crunch ]
[ Empty bottle thuds ]
Alright.
-So you don't mind?
-No, whatever you want.
-I will say the kind of story
that I would like you
to be coming here to tell.
-Okay.
-So I heard you were skiing
in Switzerland,
and you were on one of
those gondolas.
-Yeah.
-And it stopped halfway up
and you were stuck on it
with 11 strangers for 24 hours.
-It was the craziest thing.
Also it was the first time
I'd ever been there.
I'm nervous about heights
anyway.
-Sure.
-And the few times that
I'd taken the ski --
It was the two-seater, you know?
Like, the standard. I hate it.
But the great thing about being
in Switzerland, in the Alps,
they have the gondolas.
-Yeah.
Nice and warm,
protected from the elements.
-Warm, protected.
The thing is,
is when you are in there
with all of those people
and it stops,
they're from different
parts of the world.
I was the only one
who spoke English.
-Oh, God.
-Yeah! And...
[ Laughter ]
And power goes out, everything,
it shut down,
and there was no way that
we were gonna get down,
and I was really panicked.
And so I started asking people,
"What do we do?"
And no one could talk to me.
-Did you feel like any of them
even recognized you?
Because again, your movies
are internationally known.
Did you feel any recognition?
-No, not at all.
[ Laughter ]
There was one person,
one person who did recognize me.
But they were
ultimately disappointed,
because they actually pegged me
for being a writer on your show.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, right.
[ Applause ]
-All the way around.
-Wow, wow.
-Right. Oh, wow.
-Yeah.
-See, that was a great story.
-It got a little slow
in the middle.
-But I think when you can
pay it off like that --
Don't be hard --
When you get worried
about not having stories
on talk shows,
just ask for the ol' set-up.
-Yeah. That's just it.
You throw anything,
it's a much better way to go.
Did I tell you about the time
I was scuba diving
in Cozumel?
-And so just real quick
before you tell me,
happened or didn't happen?
-Didn't happen.
-Tell me.
-Well, apparently --
I'm new to scuba diving.
You're not supposed to fly
the next day.
-Oh, gotcha.
-Also, when you go below
60 feet or something,
you have to kind of
decompress for three minutes.
You get something called,
I think, nitrogen narcosis.
Something like that.
And then I you fly
the next day,
you can get the bends.
you can die.
-Oh, okay.
-I came this close...
[ Laughter ]
...to getting an early flight
out of Cozumel.
-Wow!
And you think you full-on
would have died
if you got on it?
-I know I would have died.
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
-I know I would have died.
-Talk about a dodged bullet!
-Oh, my God.
And it was only because
the flight --
we were there and there was
an issue with the plane,
so I had to wait a whole day.
It was Mexico.
There's not a lot of flights.
So I had to wait.
-And now is it true
that you actually
made a big scene about the fact
that there was a problem
with the plane?
You were like,
"Do you know who I am?"
-That's exactly right.
-And in reality, though,
you didn't realize at the time
your life was being saved.
-Had no clue.
-Wow!
-None whatsoever.
But I had to get back.
I knew I had to get back.
You know why?
-Why?
-It was the championship game
Chiefs vs. Bengals,
and I'm like,
"I can't be late to this!
My son will never forgive me!"
-Right!
But meanwhile,
he's lucky you did,
'cause otherwise, he'd be
at the Super Bowl alone
'cause his dad, dead in the air.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-What a crazy story.
-All things work out the way
they're supposed to work out.
Yeah, yeah.
And by the way,
the diving was phenomenal.
-Oh, great.
[ Laughter ]
-Real quick, three favorite
things you saw underwater.
-My three favorite things I saw?
-I know you're 60 feet
or more at this point,
but what are the three
favorite things you saw?
-Parrotfish.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-I saw an eel, which by the way,
you think, oh --
They're very hard to see,
but I was able.
I was over a bit of a reef,
and I did get to see
a moray eel.
-Okay. They're hard to see
because they move so fast?
-No, they don't like to be seen.
-Okay, gotcha.
[ Laughter ]
-And then
-So parrotfish, moray eel.
-Parrotfish, moray eel,
and then just a body.
I don't know, it was just,
like, floating.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know what happened.
I didn't follow up on it.
-Now, that's interesting.
Did you tell, or were you sort
of like, you know what?
-I was too freaked out.
I didn't say a word.
I was like, "Oh, my God.
There's just a dead body."
Maybe it went deeper
than 60 feet,
didn't take the time,
and then...
-Didn't take the class.
Everybody has to take the class
before they go diving,
and that guy was like,
"I'm fine."
"I'm fine. I got it.
You can breathe. I get it.
I'll use this.
I'll go up, I'll be able
to breathe again."
Nitrogen narcosis
knocked him out.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-What a cool -- I mean, again,
obviously not a story
he can tell,
but pretty cool that Paul Rudd
was who found him.
-He'll never know.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Thank you so much for sharing
these things that
never happened.
-I've never talked about this
before!
-It's wonderful.
You guys, that's Paul Rudd!
There's nobody better.
"Ant-Man and the Wasp:
Quantumania"
premieres in theaters and IMAX
February 17th.
We'll be right back
with Popsicle Schtick.
-I love Popsicle Schtick!